I am really glad to see that national security
experts are increasingly using a term that I've
been talking about on the program for years and
that you may now be familiar with. And that term
is stochastic terrorism to describe what
Donald Trump is doing. We have now heard
from such national security experts as Juliette
Kayyem and others who are saying that when Donald
Trump goes out there and insists that it's been
stolen and says they must resist and that they
must fight and that it's an attack on his voters
and democracy and all of these things when he
makes these claims about electoral fraud that
are both completely unequivocal from Trump,
but completely baseless. In fact, Donald Trump is
making it more likely that some of his followers
are going to go out and take to the streets
and do real world violence. And the people
that sometimes speak on Trump's behalf will
often hide behind. These are sometimes jokes
that are being told or things are being taken
too literally or whatever the case may be.
But as Juliette Kayyem points out, and this is
written about in a very good Mother Jones article,
we've also heard from others like Kori Schake and
other people. This can really encourage people to
go completely crazy with real world violence. And
the term stochastic terrorism refers to the idea
that stochastic terror terrorism refers
to random but predictable violence. OK,
if my audience is big enough and I every day
say somebody should really do something about
Joe Joe Schmoe, something somebody really needs to
deal with. The problem of Joe Schmoe, Joe Schmoe
is attacking our way of life. Joe Schmoe, if he's
allowed to continue doing what he's doing, is
going to be the end of America as we know it. If
my audience is big enough, it becomes predictable
that someone in my audience is going to take that
to heart and commit an act of real world violence.
Now, it will be random in terms of who does it,
where and when. That's that's where the term
stochastic terrorism comes from. We're talking
about a confidence interval. We're talking about,
you know, it refers to terms often used in
finance and science and relating to distributions.
But if the if you're speaking to enough people,
it becomes predictable that somebody is going
to take action. And that is exactly what a lot
of national security experts are now saying.
And senior federal law enforcement officials have
been saying that the level of concern is extremely
high, that they are seeing threatening rhetoric
and levels of anger as a result of the things
that Donald Trump and his defenders who continue
to claim he actually won. Joe Biden didn't really
win. It was stolen. There was fraud. It's all part
of the conspiracy. This is something that is very
dangerous. And I'm glad to see national security
experts speaking in no uncertain terms. And the
term stochastic terrorism is exactly the right
one. My hope is that this will not turn to real
world violence beyond what we have already seen.
And we already saw some of it at the so-called
million Magga March, which fell just a little
short of a million people over the weekend.
I hope that it doesn't come to that. Let
me know what you're thinking about this.
I'm on Twitter at De Pakman. We will take a
break and have a fantastic program for you today.